-My first guest tonight
is an Oscar-winning actress.
She stars in the new movie "F9,"
which is in theaters today.
Here is Charlize Theron.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness, come on, now!
Oh! We love you.
Charlize.
-Hi, Jimmy.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
I appreciate this
every time you come.
Congrats on "F9."
I think this --
I mean, obviously I think
it's going to be
the biggest movie.
I think this is the movie that's
going to open up movies again.
Everyone's gonna go
to the theater this weekend
and check it out.
Congrats on being in this.
This is your second one.
-Thank you.
Thank you for having --
Thank you for saying
all those kind words.
And yes, I -- Have you missed
movies, going to the theater?
'Cause I have.
-Yes, of course I have.
-So much.
-Especially with this movie,
which is --
You take it to a new level
in this "Fast and Furious."
Actually, you go to space in --
That's not a spoiler.
It's out there.
But here's what I love.
You play Cipher.
And you're a villain
in the movie,
and your hair choice,
I will say, is fantastic.
You chose a bowl cut.
And you still look cool.
[ Light laughter ]
You are just so cool-looking
that you look awesome
with a bowl cut.
Look at this.
I love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How do you pull that off?
-I don't know if I did,
but thank you
for selling it so hard.
-[ Laughing ] You did.
-You know what?
I was working on a movie
and I had shorter hair,
and I went right into the shoot
after I wrapped that film.
And I just -- I didn't have
that much hair to work with,
and we didn't have enough time
to build a wig,
so we just didn't have
that much choice.
And the only thing that
we really could do was that.
And thank God
I have so much trust
in the people that I work with.
-I pulled a similar look
when I was a child.
That was me here.
That was --
[ Laughter ]
We look like we could be
brother and sister, kind of.
-I mean, I think every kid
had, like, a bowl cut, right?
Like, I had one, too.
-Yeah, I asked you for a picture
of you with a bowl cut,
and, oh, my goodness,
this is what you sent us.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my goodness.
Stop!
Are you kidding me?
How cute is this baby?
Oh, my gosh.
You were so cute.
-Aww.
-It's the tiniest little
bowl cut.
It's like a little --
-Yet again, I didn't have
that much hair to work with.
[ Laughs ]
-Cipher's name is an alias.
You've used aliases probably
before in real life,
like if you stay at a hotel.
Do you ever stay under --
You don't stay
under your name, do you?
You change it up?
-I do.
I had one that people were
really kind of weirded out by,
which really came from
a very innocent place
because I took it
off a cereal box --
Ginger Raspberry --
but everybody thought
it was very stripper-like.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, Ginger Raspberry.
-I know.
-Coming to the stage,
put your hands together
for Ginger Raspberry.
[ Airhorn honks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, yeah.
Ginger Raspberry.
No, you can't do that.
It almost takes
more explaining than --
just put my own name down there.
-I just felt like room service
never took me serious.
-[ Laughs ] Ginger Raspberry.
I want to talk about "F9"
because you know I love
your acting.
But this acting
is a good challenge.
You act most of the movie
in a box.
You're in a Plexiglas box.
-I am. I do well
when I'm given boundaries.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Listen, I definitely think
some actors really like to have
a lot of freedom
and to use space
and things like that.
I tend to -- I have learned
over the years
that it's maybe better for me
to just have boundaries
and have somebody say,
"This is where you are,
and you're working with this."
Because I remember
when I had to audition,
when I was starting out,
and going --
First of all, I didn't know
what an audition was,
so I didn't even really know
how to prepare for it.
But the idea of walking into
an office building room
with fluorescent lights
and not having boundaries,
not having somebody say,
"This is where you are,
this is what you do,"
I -- I don't take well to it.
I have memories
of doing the craziest things,
like bringing in ketchup
and, like, squirting ketchup all
over the floor and on myself,
because I was auditioning for a
scene where I was getting shot.
And again, I just needed
a director to say,
"You don't need to do that.
You don't need to do that."
-Wait, so they go --
"Next up, Charlize.
Charlize Theron,
can you come in?"
And you would enter
already bloody, or no?
-Yes, I would do it
in the hallway.
I would kind of
tell the secretary
I'm going to get loud
for a second,
cause she's on the phone.
I was trying to be respectful,
and then I would squirt it
all over myself,
and then I just barge
into the door,
pretending like I was shot.
And I would smear ketchup
on the walls, everywhere.
Again, I need somebody to tell
me, "You can't do that.
Stay here and just
stand right here."
-There's rumors of an all-female
"Fast" spin-off.
Have you heard that,
and would you be up for it?
-I have been hearing that,
and I don't know anything,
but yes.
I mean, I think --
the thing that I will say
that I think is very impressive
about this franchise
would be the female characters.
I think the women
in this franchise are --
it's probably
one of the biggest reasons
why I wanted to be a part of it.
You know, no offense
to Vin Diesel,
but Michelle Rodriguez
is pretty badass.
-Never offense to the Diesel,
yeah.
-And so I think it's a great
idea, and I hope they do it.
If they need a baddie with
a bowl cut, I'm available.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"F9" is in theaters today.